say when when yeah you'll never guess
who's here think 90s the whole Bojack
horseman from horsing around no he got a
little fatter but it's definitely him
he looks really sad it's hilarious get
over here now I told you I don't know
where it is don't put things in my butt
if you want them back
and hold for Princess Carolyne please
thanks Laura
[Music]
Bojack it's your favorite agent yes I'm
agent you couldn't even get me in the
room for warhorse
there were like 10 horses in that movie
I didn't need to be the warhorse listen
to me I want to make sure you're all set
for your first day with Diane tomorrow
is she gonna ask me a bunch of personal
questions
the woman we're paying to ghostwrite
your memoir yeah probably
okay alright there's no need to get what
caddie are you gonna say Kat I was not
gonna say caddie I was gonna say caddie
because you're a cat
goodbye Bojack Laura I know you're
listening you got it right Laura do not
respond to him goodbye Bojack she got it
[Applause]
excuse me I just wanted you to know that
you ruin someone else's night tonight
and I hope you have enough decency to at
least feel a little bit crappy about it
excuse me I was actually already in a
bad mood but I thought maybe for one
night I could go out to a bar and try to
forget about myself but now because of
you and your friends I feel more
self-conscious than ever if we were
bothering you so much why didn't you
just leave because I didn't think of
that and now I feel stupid look I have a
right to be oh maybe because you're
skinny and maybe cuz you're pretty
you're used to getting away with things
but I want you to know that your actions
have enough effect on others and I hate
you and you are a horrible person and
you not understanding that you're a
horrible person doesn't make you less of
a horrible person you think I'm pretty
you